Dr Eugenia Cheng is a renowned
mathematician educator author and
concert pianist she's a scientist in
Residence at the school of the Art
Institute of Chicago where she teaches
mathematics to art students she is best
known for trying to rid the world of
mathematics phobia by using analogies
from baking Eugenia has written many
wonderful books exploring the world of
numbers is math real how to bake pie and
how much is X+ y really tune in to find
out once and for all why math is so much
fun hello everybody we are joined today
by a renowned author and mathematical
Muse and this is Dr Eugenia Chang of the
Art Institute of Chicago what would an
mathematician be doing at an art
institute we'll find out in today's
episode Eugenia how are you today I'm
well thank you thanks very much for
having me you've done so many things
you've written so many wonderful and
extremely popular books like how to bake
pie and X Plus Y and the today's book is
is math real so we're going to be
discussing the reality of math and I
know that math is not always real
because there are imaginary numbers and
we'll get into those maybe later on but
Eugenia as you know we have a basian
framework on this podcast how to
evaluate a book other than to judge it
by its cover so today I'm going to ask
you to play our favorite game judging
books by their covers please explain to
my audience how you came came up with
the title The subtitle and especially
the delightful artwork on the cover as
you are an artist in scholar in
Residence at an art institute take it
away well the title is math real is a
provocative question it does provoke
certain people to just answer yes or no
and think that's going to be the end of
the book but that's why there's a
subtitle because the whole book isn't
just about whether or not math is real
and the subtitle is how simple question
questions lead us to mathematics deepest
truths because it really is about how
simple and possibly naive sounding
questions can turn out to be really
profound and so each chapter of the book
starts with a simple or naive sounding
question like is math real why does 1 +
1 equal 2 why can't I divide by zero and
things like that and then weaves a story
that shows how that pushes
mathematicians into deeper and deeper
research so that's where the subtitle
comes from as for the cover art well I
have to give credit to the art
department at my wonderful publisher
basic books because it's it is the art
Department who comes up with the cover
and if you hold it up again perhaps we
can see that it's got a kind of digital
feel to it that maybe the colors are
reminiscent of I don't know the kind of
green and blue text that you might see
on a a black background if you did old
style computer programming maybe I
definitely grew up with kind of green
digitized text on black backgrounds for
the in the old monitors so maybe that's
calling to mind those early foray into
the computer world before we all used
them for everything all the time and the
idea that those early things led us into
this whole new world that we're in now
in the background there's kind of
generic looking mathy things symbols
floating around just a kind of a big
mysterious forest or Jungle of
mathematical symbols that might seem
confusing and then in the middle of it
there's this big question on top of it
that may be the question that really
taxed many people not all the answers to
the little equations and the the
integrals and the differentials but this
other luming question is math real
indeed and I like that you although I
believe that you spent some time in
England maybe maybe you're from there
you can clarify that I like that you
didn't use the word maths cuz I always
find that so I don't know I find it
insulting but uh I want to get your
reaction first of all first and foremost
to this following quote by a famous
physicist the miracle of the
appropriateness of the language of
mathematics for the formulation of the
laws of physics is a wonderful gift
which we neither understand nor deserve
and this is of course Eugene vigner who
spoke about the
unreasonable effect and the unreasonable
power of mathematics in the physic IC
Sciences how do you react to winer's
quotes do we deserve it do we understand
it we definitely don't understand it and
I think that's really important because
I think many people have put off math
because they feel like they don't
understand it and that that they've been
given the impression that that means
they're not good at it but actually none
of us understands it and that's the
whole point we accept that we will never
fully understand it but we still want to
understand more and so we that drives us
to want to understand more we don't just
go oh I don't understand it it's over we
go okay well I don't understand it yet
I'm going to understand more all the
time um as for the unreasonable
Effectiveness I sort of think it's
reasonable I think it's a reasonable
Effectiveness because it's the use of
reason that's at the core of everything
and as for whether we deserve it well
that's a complicated question what do
humans deserve in one sense we we behave
badly we destroy the environment we're
horrible to people we don't deserve much
on the other hand we all deserve
wonderful things because because we're
all just trying and so maybe we do
deserve it I don't know that deserving
is is something that is easy to work out
is it a gift you know I mean I think if
you talk to a lot of you know fifth
graders doing you know rational and
irrational numbers they'll say uh if
it's a gift you can have it back uh
vigner called it a gift what do you make
of that uh uh of that kind of notion
that such tools and I believe somebody
once said that math uh is the machine or
the tool that has saved the most human
labor throughout history so uh why is
there such an outsized kind of
differential between the appreciation of
math and its power I mean nobody says I
hate this iPhone you know it's too
powerful it seems like a magical gift
it's a piece of Rock with electrons in
it and it and it allows me to talk to
you right so how can we explain this
discrepancy between the benefits and the
public perception of mathematics well
first of all I would like to point out I
think some people do hate iPhones and I
think there some people those are
Android users eug those are heathens
they are Android users we do not discuss
them personally I personally have big
trouble with with touch screens I can't
do touch screens because I feel like my
finger's in the way all the time and
that that it upsets my brain that my
finger in the way of what I'm trying to
do so I'll just put that out there for a
second I think that the trouble is that
too many people have been put off they
may well appreciate the fact that
someone else has done it so I think most
people are glad that techn not all but
many people are glad that it has been
done and that technology exists and that
that all of these developments have
happened there are problems with those
developments but many people think well
I that doesn't mean I have to do it
myself and I think the problem is that
what happens in mainstream math
education is so much about testing
people and separating out people into
those who are good and those who are not
good and we don't really focus very much
on just the appreciation of it and I
think it would be wonderful to have math
appreciation as a really conscious part
of math education and to acknowledge
that it's really important to preserve
the appreciation of math all the way
through rather than just trying to to
drum facts and algorithms and techniques
into people's brains if in the process
of doing that you kill off the
appreciation because the process was so
painful then I think we've really done a
disservice to everybody and to
mathematics you have man wonderful
illustrations in the book it's such a
rich and enjoyable book one of the parts
I enjoy the most is you show like a
square at one point and you just have
the numbers you know one and one on the
two sides of the square and it's to
introduce the concept of the irrational
length of the hypotenuse is square root
of two and then you say well what what
about the units I haven't put the units
in and then you say never mind it's it's
irrelevant what the units are uh and I'm
I'm an experimental physicist so you
know for me the the notion of you know
just shut up and calculate don't think
about you know is this real or is this
not real but I want to ask you a
philosophical question if there were no
physical world you know would math exist
in other words we can conceive of things
like a triangle uh but you can't hand me
a triangle and we can conceive of
Infinity but there's nothing possibly
that's infinite right so or else it
would crowd out most of everything else
so I wonder if you can explain in your
opinion does math exist independent of a
physical world and a quote unquote real
world well first of all I mean this is
how I address the question is math real
in the book what does real mean and I'm
glad you put quote unquote around it
because if I think about it too hard I
can come to the conclusion that nothing
is real I'm not real you are not real is
anything real what's going on nothing's
real it's all a figment of my
imagination I think that this is what
deart was probably taxing himself about
do we exist all this kind of thing I
think that if we accept that anything is
real then I think ideas are real they
are real Concepts they just happen to be
abstract we can't touch them but there
are plenty of real things that we can't
touch I think Love is Real but we can't
touch it hunger is real we can't touch
that either I think that the planets are
like the sun is real we can't touch the
sun the center of the earth is real we
can't touch that either and so I think
that the idea of realness is is
confusing and possibly a red herring and
I think what's more important is does it
help us and I think that it does help us
just in the same way that for example
fiction and works of literature the
stories in those works of literature
aren't real they didn't happen but it's
still real literature and that real
literature can give us real insights to
the part of the world that we do
consider to be real I think a lot of you
know what uh really amused me about the
book was you know the the different
various categories and maybe we're going
to get into a discussion of what
category theory is because despite my
father being a mathematician I've never
really understood it but the various
examples from geometry to algebra uh set
theory imaginary numbers complex numbers
real numbers but the number that kind of
speaks loudest in this book is zero uh
for for a variety of reasons and I
always think zero is is sort of it seems
almost like a magical number uh in that
it's maybe not real it's for example in
cosmology the universe can have a
variety of different shapes it can have
spatial geometries that are positively
curved negatively curved or could have
zero curvature but uh there's an
infinite number of radi of curvature you
know corresponding to different size
positive curvature spheres there's an
infinite number of of negatively curved
numbers that could have been chosen for
the universe's curvature but we live in
a universe that's precisely zero it's
precisely flat there's something strange
about that can you talk about zero is it
invented was it discovered would we have
uh had to uh come upon it by some other
means maybe an alien brought it here
what about zero why is it so fascinating
zero is fascinating because it is a
thing that represents nothing and that
is a difficult thing to get our heads
around and if we think about teaching
small children numbers I love teaching
small children about numbers because I
love watching their heads get around
things before they've been infected by
the fear that testing uh brings to so
many people and the thing about zero is
you can't show someone zero because it's
not there you can show them one and two
and three and four things and you
gradually see the pattern but how do you
show them zero and I was reminded of
this very strongly when I one day posted
on social media that I realized I had
one one whole hole punch two two hole
hole punches and three three hole hole
punches and someone said to me you also
have Z zero hole hole punches and I sat
there and I thought about it and I
thought I don't think I do actually I
think I I think every object I own is a
zero whole hole punch because everything
I own is sitting around punching zero
holes all the time and so you can look
once you realize that zero is everywhere
now I hope everyone can can see that in
their house now there are zero elephants
unless you have an elephant in your
house which you might do but I have zero
elephants in my house I have zero
giraffes now I can see Zero things
everywhere so now zero is even more
confusing because it's it's everywhere
one minute it was nowhere and the next
minute it was everywhere and it took it
took humans a really long time between
getting comfortable with the numbers 1 2
3 and so on and then deciding that zero
could also count as a number and they
went from just representing it as a gap
and then when you do when you represent
numbers using place value we kind of
need the zeros in order to say that
there are none of those so if you have
places where you have one un units and
you have tens and you have hundreds how
do you represent the fact that there's
nothing if you've got no tens and you're
going straight to the hundreds you can
leave a gap but that's kind of confusing
so then you need a symbol to represent
it but that's still not regarding zero
to be an actual number it's just a
symbol and so then it took even more
time I'm not a historian of mathematics
but I just find it fascinating that
there was so much suspicion about the
idea of treating zero as a number and I
think it was very contentious for a long
time and it's actually still contentious
among some particularly I shouldn't be
too judgmental I'll just say a certain
kind of math person who gets really
taxed about whether zero should count as
a natural number or not because the
natural numbers are the ones we used to
count and so some people still think
zero shouldn't be one of those because
we're not counting things we're counting
the absence of things and that's a very
confusing thing and I think it's
important for us to acknowledge how
confusing it is because if we just go
around saying oh it's really obvious
then the people who don't find it
obvious feel stupid and I think that's
something that has put a lot of people
off math in the normal course of their
math education whereas if we acknowledge
that it's actually quite strange and
that it is quite weird and that in order
to progress in mathematics we accept it
but we still hold on to the idea that
it's a bit strange and so there's this
thing that we do in our heads where we
accept that it's strange and we also
keep going with it and that's a really
wonderful thing to be able to do and I
think that's key for for getting to
grips or or moving forward in MA
mathematics it's accepting that things
are weird and also going ahead as well
well I want to ask you uh when it comes
to building designs which annoys you
more the the fact that in the UK they
have a floor zero uh which we call the
first floor here in America as you know
and in America if a building has more
than 14 floors there's no button for the
number 13 in the elevator so my favorite
thing to do and when I go to a highrise
is ask the people in the elevator could
you push floor 13 for me and they look
around it's not there which annoys you
more the kind of superstition around
numbers or this notion that you know
there's a the you know zero if is uh is
this special number that's really not
given the kind of uh attention or
respect that it might deserve actually
neither of those things annoys me too
much because I've lived I grew up in the
UK and I've lived in the US for 12 years
now and if I allowed the cultural
differences to irritate me then it would
just be an ongoing irritation all the
time and there are so many things in the
world to be irritated about that are
more important than that that I have
accepted I've have accepted those things
what does irritate me more I will say
about zero is when people insist that
the Millennium didn't start until
200 one that it didn't start at 2000
because there was no year zero and I
think to myself well first of all there
wasn't a year 1 2 3 or four I understand
and that the current way of ordering
years didn't start until about 500 plus
when the digits change when the first
digit of a number changes that is a big
deal even if it doesn't if you if you're
going to be pedantic about it and I
think most of the people doing that who
are pointing out that there was no U
zero what they're really trying to do is
assert some kind of superiority as if
they have some secret knowledge and when
mathematical concepts are used to assert
superiority then I I never like that
they shouldn't be there to assert
superiority they should be there to help
us and shed light hey friends just a
short request to ask you to use your
thumb while my thumb is occupied to
leave a like on this video and don't
forget to subscribe it really helps us
with the algorithm now back to the
episode one topic that's not directly
addressed in the book although it's you
know rotten perhaps throughout all of
mathematics nowadays is artificial
intelligence and computability of
numbers we've had on you know uh sir
Roger Penrose many times we've had on
Steven Wolfram and many others Steven
stroget many mathematicians um I wonder
if you could speculate on this one of my
Arguments for you know the kind of non-c
concern that I have with artificial
intelligence is that there's things that
are very good for computers to do uh
that computers are very good at doing
but the human brain uh can't do and
conversely uh the converse is true as
well there are things the human brain
can do like represent infinity a
computer represents Infinity by the
largest number in its possible registers
that it can represent it doesn't really
represent the way that we think of
Infinity uh which is maybe abstract but
we can at least manipulate Infinities
which a computer will you know throw up
at uh so I wonder if you have any
thoughts about the you know the issue of
of what is unique in the in the mind and
the human brain about the ability that
we have to be to compute to compute
numbers to work with Concepts that a
computer cannot do you think of the
brain as a massive computer or is there
something inherently advantageous about
the brain that allows it to manipulate
numbers as if they were real as your
book speculates I do think of the brain
as a massive computer actually but I
also know that it's an organic thing and
so it physically changes as it goes
along and so that's what makes it so
much more spectac ularly complicated and
hard for us to understand and it's
really important for us to remember that
it has enormous plasticity because
that's how we learn to do things and
that when we're learning to do things
and I'm not a neuroscientist but as I
understand it when we learn to do things
our brain is actually physically
changing and whereas when a I don't know
that a computer physically changes that
much as it's doing things whereas our
brain really changes it lays down layers
I think and it makes new connections and
so our brain really changes as it goes
along
and I think that's important because so
many people are limited in mathematics
by a belief that may have come from
other people that they are bad at math
and that they can't do it and if they've
been told that enough then they start
believing it and once you believe you
can't do something you pretty much can't
do it and I don't know that that's a
drawback I didn't answer the question
because I said a drawback instead I I
don't think computers have that drawback
I don't think they get psyched out about
the fact that they don't think they're
going to be able to do something but I
think that that there are I would never
say that AI will never be able to do
things first of all I'm not that afraid
of AI because I'm more afraid of natural
stupidity than artificial intelligence
also I feel like the the AI is so bad at
stalking me when they try and show me
personalized adverts they're so badly
tailored to me that I can't believe that
unless it's some kind of giant
conspiracy to fool me into thinking I'm
I don't need to be afraid of them
they're so bad at understanding anything
that I want so there is also that but I
also from a point of view of a
mathematician there are things I think
are currently still so far beyond I
think that that machines would be much
better at doing things like having an
immediate knowledge of all the
literature if only we humans have told
them what the literature is so first of
all we have to find a way to explain to
AI what is in the literature so that's a
huge Monumental undertaking in the first
place but then it's about making
connections where you have some kind of
idea how do we come up with an idea and
taxes me a lot because I often need to
come up with an idea and when I'm doing
research there is very rarely a deadline
on when I need to come up with an idea
but there are other things I do where I
have to come up with an idea to a
deadline and so for example if I'm
writing a column there's a deadline and
I need an idea how do you come up with
an idea it's really interesting and so I
don't know if we understand that enough
to teach AI how to do it it can sift
through huge quantities of information
but when we remember when we're reminded
of something quite often when I have an
idea I'm just reminded of something and
I don't know even why I was reminded of
it my brain has made some connection
that I'm not even conscious of and I
couldn't even put into words how it made
that connection and so I don't know how
that happens or if I come up with an
idea for how to represent in mathematics
you often spot a pattern and then you
have to come up with an idea for how to
represent it how do we come up with that
I don't know those are the really deep
human things that I think are the
furthest down the line from from what AI
could do I'm not an expert in AI either
I've been sitting here saying all the
things I'm not an expert in but I would
never say never because I know that we
have a very poor understanding of what
could happen technologically in the
future but I think those are the things
that are are currently furthest away
this gentleman here longtime listeners
know I'm a fan of finger puppets and my
daughter kept this one kindly nearby uh
but this man said once he was asked a
woman came up and asked him allegedly uh
to help her you know she has such
trouble with mathematics and and he uh
reportedly said don't tell me about your
troubles with mathematics I have my own
and I always think back and
computability and artificial
intelligence Etc and I always respond to
people that do believe that the brain is
essentially a big computer like Donald
Hoffman who's been a past guest or um
believes it's essentially a way of
Consciousness is a way of you know
evolutionarily dealing with
computability and information overload
but this man said uh that he had one of
his happiest thoughts in life and that
was that if he was in freef Fall he
would experience no gravitational field
and that led him to the Einstein
equivalence principle which is the
Bedrock of general relativity which is
basically a set of 84 different partial
differential equations that define
space-time curvature but I always like
to point out like how do I tell my
iPhone you know what's what is it like
to freefall how do I tell it uh what is
the happiest thought uh you know how do
I tell what a painful thought is do I
you know pull out one of its circuit
boards or what have you so I like you I
am not too concerned about the uh the uh
kind of paperclip problem taking AI
takeover I think there are things the
human brain is is uniquely capable to do
and one of the things you're uniquely
capable of doing I think is explaining
in in in terms that people can
understand starting with your your first
book I believe which was how to bake pie
so how did that idea come to you how did
you have this happiest thought perhaps
uh which launched your your brilliant
career what was the what was sort of the
Genesis the zero point of that
particular Adventure was very gradual
there wasn't one specific thing that
started it but for my whole life I've
enjoyed helping other people to
understand things and my upbringing of
my education have always given me the
belief in the principle that help
helping others is really important in
whatever way that you can and for me it
turned out that helping other people
understand mathematics was some way that
I could contribute to that and I always
believed in education as a really
important social good to help others who
don't necessarily have as good a start
in life as everyone else does and so for
me wanting to go into education to help
other people understand mathematics was
a very obvious path and then it
gradually became that I wanted to help
people who had been put off mathematics
because I realized that when I was
teaching math in normal universities to
math students I was not reaching as many
people as I wanted and that those people
could be taught by somebody else that if
I stopped teaching calculus to
undergraduate somebody else would teach
calculus but the way I saw it there
weren't enough research level
mathematicians who wanted to talk about
abstract mathematics to people who were
fundamentally very afraid of math
and so I decided I wanted to do more of
that and I had been talking to my
students who some of my students at the
at the University I was teaching at
weren't that Keen on abstract math they
wanted to go into Finance or accounting
and so they were really interested in
the more applied things but they were
made to do the abstract part they were
reluctant and so I told them all sorts
of stories from my life to try and bring
abstract math to life because the
trouble with abstract math is it's
really abstract which means it's very
removed from daily life which is also
the powerful thing it gets its power
from being removed from life but then it
means that we can't relate to it in the
same way until we've got used to the
abstract world so I told them all sorts
of stories from my life and they always
perked up when I told them stories from
my life they especially perked up when I
told them stories involving food and so
then that became a whole book because I
realized there was so many stories I
could tell about food and math and
baking and cooking and creating things
and and Building Things that that became
an entire book and that was that was how
how to bake pie came about and each
chapter is a kind of gives a recipe as
well for dessert I believe I remember
that book correctly uh was very c not
all desserts but there is definitely a
focus on desserts because that is my
favorite thing to make as I love to say
I love making dessert because it has
absolutely no nutritional value and so
it exists just for my pleasure that's
right exactly like uh we have the
holiday of Labor Day you know which
always comes after the uh the long
summer and it's like do you need a
second dessert you know
after uh so that book had elements of
category Theory which is your area of
expertise I wonder if you could explain
category Theory why didn't I never hear
about it until say 10 years ago uh what
is responsible for its you know meteoric
like rise category theory is quite a
recent branch of mathematics and until
recently it was considered to be
research level and so it was thought
that you couldn't possibly learn it
unless you had already got through an
entire ire undergraduate math degree and
it was also thought that it would only
be useful to Pure mathematicians because
it's what it does is it makes a theory
of math for math just like math is kind
of a theory at the root of science
category theory is like the theory at
the root of mathematics and then what
happened is that it gradually expanded
its reach and people realized it was
really helpful to things Way Beyond pure
mathematics and that started with
theoretical physics and theoretical
computer science and then it moved into
chemistry and biology and ecology and
engineering and then it expanded further
into Linguistics and then it it once it
got out of the realm of mathematics
there were people who wanted to learn
about it who had did not have a
mathematics undergraduate degree anymore
and so then it became a thing that
people wanted to learn without having a
math undergraduate degree which is why I
wanted to start talking about it but the
other reason I wanted to start talking
about it is because I think it's really
great and because it doesn't really have
prerequisites you don't don't have to
know calculus in order to do category
Theory you don't have to know any high
school math really you just have to be
curious because what category Theory
says and I think it has really important
principles at the root of it as well
it's not about categorizing things it's
a very it's a technical use of the word
category it's not just like oh we put
this in this category and that that
category what it's saying is that we can
understand the world around us by
looking at how things relate to each
other rather than by looking at their
intrinsic characteristics and and so in
mathematics often what we do is we're
not just studying things we're studying
Transformations between things and the
maps between things and so in Calculus
if you've ever done any calculus then
actually what's important in calculus is
really the concept of a continuous map
it's all there to think about continuity
and what it means for things to be
continuous and so category Theory says
actually it's those relationships
between things that are really important
and it doesn't really matter what the
intrinsic characteristics of of
something are what matters is how it
relates to the stuff around it so you
could write 25 books about what the
number two is but in the end it doesn't
matter what the number two is what
matters is how the number two relates to
the number one and the number three and
the number four and all of that and that
was the big Insight of category Theory
and it turns out that loads of things
get really illuminated by that including
for example whether you like it or not
large language models which as I
understand it and again I'm not an
expert in that but it's about you make a
model of a language so that you don't
have to understand what individual words
mean you understand where they fit into
the rest of the language and then you
map the entire language onto another
language and you find the same spot so
you find the point that relates to the
things around it in the same way that
that one related to the things around it
and that's how you translate between
things and it can even translate between
words and pictures so you make a whole
Space of pictures and how they relate to
each other and then you can find the
corresponding Place according to how it
relates to other things and I think it's
also really important for how we think
about people in society because I think
in the end what equality of people
should mean is not that people are equal
cuz we're not equal everyone is
different but what matters is how we
relate to other people it shouldn't
matter what our intrinsic
characteristics are you know it
shouldn't matter what we look like and
what all those things what matters is
how we treat other people and I think
that's fundamentally what category
theory is about it's about thinking via
relationships and putting everything in
a context according to how it relates to
the stuff around it I wonder if you can
comment a little bit on some of the uses
that I've seen in just a little bit of
Google searching things where people are
attempting to kind of categorize people
groups individuals uh in in terms of
language of of category theory is that
some sort of mathw washing or have you
encountered this I know you've thought a
lot about gender and equality and
privilege and so forth in the
mathematical Sciences can you comment on
you know is there a dark side is there
mathematical washing that going on with
category Theory or is am I totally I
think there sometimes is mathematical
washing but often what happens is that
people invoke the word math to try and
finish an argument and some although I
don't like that because that's misuse of
math but in a way it to me it shows that
at least there is awareness that math is
the very powerful thing but we shouldn't
misuse it and we shouldn't just pay
spirous homage to it by saying oh well
mathematically people say things like oh
well mathematically that can't happen
and I think well what do you mean you
you just actually you don't know whether
it can happen or not but you've invoked
the word mathematically to try and
finish the argument but what I do think
about people and I've done this myself
because I've used some category Theory
some very basic category Theory to
understand the interactions between
people what I do think it helps with is
understanding the interactions of groups
of people within structures because
unfortunately our society is made up of
power hierarchies and if we can
understand people according to where
they fit inside different Power
hierarchies and the fact that there
isn't just one but there are many along
different dimensions and they might not
agree with each other that is something
that I find very helpful and the point
about uh learning category Theory and
Mathematics is something you referred to
before about using our brain to
basically deal with a complex world I'm
paraphrasing what you said but it's to
to me it's to do with being able to
understand more complex structures so
that we don't have to simplify so much
because we do have to simplify the world
in order to understand it that's
inevitable because the world is really
complicated and our brains are tiny but
if we simplify it by just ignoring
important details that's not a very good
way of simplifying it if we simplifying
it by packaging things up into
structures that we can then understand
in single Le unit that's a really great
way to simplify it because what in a way
we've done is we've become more
intelligent so that the world has become
simpler relative to our ability to
understand it so I wonder if you could
wait in a little bit on something that's
bothered me uh quite significantly is
this notion that saying that there are
mathematical truths is rolent of white
supremacy recently or in the last year
or so there was Article published uh
somewhere in Toronto I think and it was
speaking to the fact that you know if
you say that there's one right answer 2
plus 2 equals F four uh that you're
somehow enforcing you know some sort of
ideological or racist notion and I I did
a search I went to the uh University of
iidon which is in Nigeria and Covenant
University and the University of Lagos
and these are all you know top thousand
universities in the world nowhere in
their math department do they teach
anything other than 2 plus 2 equals 4 so
I wonder what do you what do you
attribute first of all what what do you
make of this notion that having a
correct answer is somehow you know
reminiscent or reinforcing of the idea
of of something to do with color or race
um I I find it sort of abor but but what
what is your what's your impression I
think there's a lot of nuance here
because I think the first thing I want
to to challenge is the idea that nobody
teaches anything other than 2 plus 2
equal 4 I teach that 2 plus two can be
anything because 2 plus 2 can be
anything and actually the idea that
there's only one right answer is a very
narrow view of mathematics which is not
the way research mathematicians see it
the way research mathematicians and
because we're talking about this I
should say research mathematicians as
defined by the framework of mathematics
that was built by European white men in
the in the 18th or 19th century
according to that framework there are
many different possible answers and what
we do is we find the context in which
different things are true so 2 + 2 equal
4 in the natural numbers and the real
numbers and various other number systems
but in other number systems 2 plus 2 can
equal different things and we study
those contexts as different mathematical
worlds so I don't think mathematics has
absolute truth I think that the
mathematics provides context in which
different things are true and I think
it's a very subtle difference that and
the thing is that many people get upset
when I say that because they want to
cling to the idea that math does have
absolute right and wrong and I just
think that's an unrealistic view of what
research mathematics is and I think that
it is definitely exclusionary because
what it's saying is that we're I going
to I have decided that I'm going to
gatekeep this form of Truth and I'm not
going to let anything else be true now
while I don't think that that is
directly a form of white supremacy I do
think it's related and here's why and
it's a very long story that I find very
uncomfortable to think about so the
history of mathematics is very very long
mathematics has been been developed by
human civilizations across the world
since the beginning of human
civilizations and it has really got all
its starts in non-white cultures in
ancient civilizations and again I'm not
a historian of mathematics but including
ancient Egypt Mesopotamia Maya native
cultures Arab cultures India China right
Africa and but it it did gradually
developed in various different ways and
then
the academic mathematics that we know
know now had a framework that was
defined by a bunch of white male
Europeans who sat down and decided that
mathematics needed a rigorous framework
in order to be really really sure that
their foundations were completely
rigorous and what you get out of
rigorous foundations is that you can
build more complicated structures so if
you just want to build a heart you don't
need deep foundations right if you want
to build a skyscraper you need really
really solid foundations in order to
build higher and that's what this
rigorous form of mathematics has done it
means that we can really build really
serious complexity and that has what is
what has enabled spectacular advances in
science and technology in the last
couple of hundred years which is amazing
and I love it but I also recognize that
it's very it's makes me uncomfortable
because those extraordinary developments
are also what have enabled some people
in the world to exploit other people in
the world because technology whether it
is in the form of weapons or in the form
of computer technology is what has has
enabled a lot of imperialism and
colonialism and exploitation and that
makes me very uncomfortable especially
because I know that another side effect
of us doing that is that we're
destroying the environment that we
depend on whereas native cultures who
didn't make those extraordinary
developments perhaps probably understood
much better how to live in harmony with
the environment and not destroy it so
what is it that we've done exactly I
don't know I think it makes me
uncomfortable but I do think that those
things are related I don't think it is
white supremacy to say that 1 plus 1
equals 2 even if you acknowledge that 1
plus 1 equals 2 in the real in the real
numbers I think if you think that 1+ 1
always equals 2 you're actually just
wrong and that's a whole different
question from whether it's white
supremacy I always say you know if basic
books decides you know they're going to
give pay you in two installments you
know equal amounts uh it better add up
to the advance that you were promised
right you're not going to say well well
that's because that's the Contex that is
the context of natural is a
very for a lay person right they'll say
you know you adding you know comparing
apples and oranges right so you can add
one apple to one orange and that's two
fruit but then that's the category of
fruit as I've learned you know from from
you you know if I've learned nothing
else uh but uh but you can't add you
don't get two apples and you don't get
two oranges right so so I think
colloquially there is a lay person
should should not you know just as you
said before that people make math out to
be you know say you're stupid if you
don't understand this or they give you
uh the this this impression of math
anxiety because you don't understand or
math doesn't come as naturally so too we
shouldn't also you know kind of
obfuscate what we do and say in no
circumstance and you didn't say this I'm
I'm just I'm just saying what I've heard
and that's where I would push back and
say look if it was white supremacy I
wouldn't see Africans in Nigeria that
would teach in the in the appropriate
category as you point out these These
are facts or these are truths or these
are proofs uh and and that's what I
think I think the lay person might react
to and I think that's why I got
attention I I don't want to dwell too
much on on this but but I did want to
ask you because you did touch upon
education and you did touch upon you
know the history of teaching you know as
as being generated from Europeans um and
I want to ask in in one of your chapters
you have this illustration and I I
called it like in my notes I call it
like the stupid question
resonance cycle uh and let me see if I
can find yeah here it is um it starts in
the following way students ask a
disingenuous question teachers give a
dismissive answer and there's a sort of
fly negative flywheel and I'm wondering
education really hasn't changed you
pointed out it's European yes that's
true the first major Western University
was in bolognia in the year 1080 almost
nothing has changed there still like uh
some person standing up with a piece of
rock scraping on another piece of Rock
the only thing Eugene I say is better
back then they used to the students
could go on strike and then we
professors wouldn't get paid so that
that's barbaric and I'm glad that
they've outlawed that and we have tenure
now um talk about education and before
you do how we can Revitalize and
modernize education and then can you
first speculate on that flywheel that
disingenuous and dismissive circle what
are the pernicious effects of that
feedback
cycle well because my whole book is
about how simple questions are really
important that the trouble is that some
questions are disingenuous that students
are asking them to try and catch
teachers out or to try and poke at them
or rebel against the system and then as
a result teachers may feel that they're
being undermined which they probably are
and then they can't give a a genu answer
to the question or they feel that that
because the student thinks the students
think that they can catch a teacher out
by asking a question the teacher can't
answer and so then the teacher feels
they have to be able to answer every
question otherwise they'll be caught out
and so if they can't answer a question
then they have to do something to
protect themselves which may be to say
that the question is a bad question
whereas actually what we should do I
think is to create a an environment in
which it's fine if a teacher can't
answer a question because then that's a
good it's a great question then we can
what we can do is we can all sit down
and learn how to figure out the answer
to a question using the resources around
us there's an entire inter internet we
can look anything up and then we can
learn how to discover things and then it
won't matter if a student asks a
question a teacher can't answer so then
hopefully the disingenuous questions
will go away because there will be no
social cache left to being able to to
ask a question and teacher can't answer
so then students will only ask things
that they generally want to know so the
other type of disingenuous question is
when students ask things just to show
how clever they are and I always talk to
my students at the beginning of the
semester saying I don't want to know how
clever anyone is I'm not interested and
unfortunately mainstream education is
all about that it's all there to test
how clever people are but luckily I
teach at art school and it's nothing to
do with how clever him is what I want to
know is how curious people are and how
deeply they are prepared to think about
something and how open they are prepared
to be in thinking about different points
of view and so in that case the
questions where they're posturing or
showing how clever they are those
question questions will go away because
they're not rewarded while we carry on
rewarding Behavior humans are just at
some level basic animals if you reward
Behavior then the behavior continues and
if you stop rewarding Behavior the
behavior will probably stop and so I
always want to nurture a classroom
environment where I try to convince
everyone that I will not reward the
posturing behavior that I think it's
wonderful if they ask me a question I
can't answer and where any question
stemming from curiosity is a good
question and that I will take it
seriously and I won't let anyone else in
the room make people feel stupid for it
because the thing that then stops the
genuine questions is if you're worried
that someone's going to say that you're
stupid and I know this happens because I
felt it people have told me at all sorts
of levels that my questions are stupid
and so it's not something that people
have made up and you can't I don't think
it's right to just say oh stop being so
scared of asking questions because the
the danger is real if you have a have
been humiliated by other people no one I
might say no one but most of us don't
like being humiliated in front of other
people and so we will try to avoid it so
the other thing is to stop humiliating
people if they are perhaps slower at
understanding something and I always say
to my students if you're slower at
understanding something it might be
because you're seeking deeper
understanding and mathematicians seek
really deep understanding and so we
spend ages thinking about things that
might seem simple because we don't feel
like we've really understood it yet okay
uh Dr Chen we have reached the segment
where I like to take audience questions
and we have a few too many to actually
take in the remaining five minutes or so
that we allotted for the podcast but I'm
going to ask one for my good good friend
Alex Bilzerian who follows us on Twitter
and you can follow Dr Chang at Dr
Eugenia Chang on uh Twitter or X now
they call it now you must like that
right the joy of X right um Alex asked
the following or X Plus y I should say
so we we need to find an app called y
you need to you need to build one then
you could then you could be Mega wealthy
um I'll say I knew you went uh question
from Alex is uh how do you resolve the
ontological tension between mathematics
as a human constructed formalism and as
a domain of discoverable entities and he
has a follow-up question after that so I
did see that question on Twitter so I
looked some words up because those are
big words and I thought maybe everyone
else would like to know what those words
mean as well so I looked up ontology
because it's one of those philosophy
words that I can never remember what it
means because I don't think about it
very much I think it means something to
do with what it the the state of being
or something like what it means to be
and so I think what this question is
asking in simpler terms is isn't it
about whether math is created or
discovered that's what it's asking
invented or yeah invented or invented
invented or discovered right and so I
think it's both and I think that very
often we ask questions that have a
premise of a false dichotomy inside them
and instead of saying is it this or this
I prefer to say in what sense is it this
and in what sense is it that and I think
that there is a sense in which it is is
created because we come up with we
create ways to talk about the ideas that
we see around us and there's a sense in
which it is discovered because we're
just wandering around looking at things
around us and then they start tying into
each other because once you've created a
way of thinking about something or you
have said it's like it's like inventing
the rules for a game you can invent the
rules for a game and then explore what
happens in that game and at that point
you're discovering what happens in the
game so whoever invented the rules for
chess invented them but now there's all
sorts of discoveries about how chess
works and then you're discovering the
consequences so it's like discovering
the consequences of some idea you came
up with and I think it's really both of
those things in in different ways well
we spoke about the prospects of you
becoming a billionaire I I should
mention that none other than Jim Simons
who is a very good friend of mine who
was one of the first mathematicians I
had on the podcast I asked him that same
question is math discovered or invented
and he said yes he said both so uh
you're in very good company with another
billionaire Eugenia
congratulations so the last uh thing I
want to ask you about is related to the
name of this podcast so this podcast is
called the into the impossible podcast
because I am uh the associate director
of the Arthur C Clark Center for human
imagination and Sir Arthur C Clark had
all these wonderful things and also he
would have liked you very much because
he was very much interested in Art and
Science and we didn't talk about your
piano playing and your leader later uh I
assume that goes with the hosen I'm not
sure you tell me if that's if that's
wrong no no ler is leather and leader is
songs was that a dad joke yes it was it
was just checking thank you I'm glad you
got it I'm glad you got it it's in my
Twitter profile so that's all I that's
all I can be held responsible for but I
want to ask you a question related to
sort of advice to your younger self and
it's the following Sir Arthur C Clark
said the only way of determining the
limits of the possible is to go beyond
them into the impossible and I like to
phrase this in terms of a question
that's predicated on you going back in
time you know teleporting back in time
you've got 30 seconds with pre- Doctor
Chang and you're going to tell her some
piece of advice to give her the courage
to do as she will later do to go into
the impossible what advice do you give
to your younger pre-doctoral
self I think I'd say that the people who
have more confidence in themselves it's
not necessarily because they're wiser or
better they've just got more confidence
in themselves and it might be because
they're deluded wonderful Eugenia well
can I uh ask you to summarize where
should people find you what would you
like to point people towards give
yourself this is the plugs zone so
please feel free to plug away well my
website is my name www. Eugenia chan.com
and I am on the place formerly known as
Twitter as Dr Eugenia Chen very good and
you can get this book now it's out and
by the time this episode which probably
take a couple weeks to process comes out
it'll be available and hopefully it'll
be uh number one or you know uh as close
to number one on the bestselling charts
as possible uh that's my that's my
second favorite number after zero right
you don't want to be zero but uh but
hopefully may may you be one uh Eugenia
thank you so much for joining us today
thank you so much